[Music]
Adam Brody stars and startup finally
found that warrant so he took them down
memory lane to when his career first
started up first audition that you ever
went on I like that question I can't
remember specifically about some very
early ones the Power Rangers maybe
definitely Dawson's Creek I read with
Scott Speedman I didn't get it for the
role of Pacey no no no after is like
later on that was like my first like it
felt like what was his real TV show and
I Blue's Clues
um I to be they dude to be like a guy
bean I would have killed for that role
when I was like 19 20 I remember going
this would be an all right life this dog
and me on this children's show the first
thing that you realized that I was fear
was Omega hits I do remember that we you
know even filming the pilot like we got
picked up very early like almost almost
during or a week after I don't really
have a fame story or yeah but I do
remember that it seemed like we were
getting a lot of green lights yeah even
his wallet philipot open to the idea of
reunion ever
you know Adam not so up for the idea of
going back to the OC but season do have
startup premieres Thursday on crackle
baggage yeah there's a little bit of
baguette of modena nosy walk me through
what next headspace is as we pick up
he's on the outs he's got an open FBI
investigation against him so he's
waiting tables professionally speaking
he's lower than he was in the first
season Ron Perlman is joining you in
front of the camera you guys co-produced
the show together behind the scenes what
is it like having him on set with you on
a daily basis and working with him
well he's a legend I mean he's a real
character and he's got an amazing face
and voice and presence is such a treat
to see great actor say some say some
dialogue and front performs some
dialogue with you in front of you it's
as good dance partner and and he's a
generous guy too generous actor how do
you go into choosing roles with this new
chapter in your life your dad you're
married when I was on my own you know I
was up for traveling wherever and it was
always great you know it home didn't
have quite the same meaning so I didn't
feel you know it wasn't hard to be away
from it and and now I you know they just
think it certainly is a much bigger
factor where it's gonna be and and
that's the biggest way I really think
that this could be not only the new
darknet I think it could be the new
internet for a show that explores the
interwebs and the dark that's you and
your real life are seemingly absent from
social media
I know if you're opposed but why are you
definitely not definitely not opposed
and it's part laziness and uh in part
yeah it seems like on one hand I will
eventually because I want to be part of
the 21st century so I feel like I'm
gonna have to it and that's fine
but for the moment I'm quite happy with
my life and I don't I don't I don't mess
with it
you've been very protective of your
family and your personal life is that
part of the reason would you say yes but
I mean it seems like that said you know
you can go on you can you can also be
very professional you don't have to
share you don't have to overshare he
shares a little or what do I know I
don't know tell me should I do it I
think you should do it I probably do
everyone say I don't know if I should
say
[Music]